[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros en cisjordania un territorio
palestino ocupado por israel desde 1967
y donde las colonias se multiplican el
primer ministro israelí benyamín
netanyahu ordenó recientemente la
construcción de 800 nuevas viviendas en
esta región que el estado de israel
llama judea y samaria en alusión a los
nombres bíblicos viven alrededor de 2
millones 800 mil palestinos al lado de
400 mil israelíes estas colonias son
juzgadas como ilegales por el derecho
internacional pero los planes de
expansión siguen y las tensiones
comentan a los palestinos de la zona ni
siquiera se les permite tener
electricidad y viven en lo que muchos de
ellos llaman una guerra silenciosa cuya
arma son sus propias viviendas el
siguiente reportaje está hecho en las
colinas del sur de hebrón donde dos
mundos el judío y el árabe conviven
incómodos uno al lado del otro
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ya
las olas
louis murió julio
y
desde el primero de enero los días de la
familia afuera se organizan en torno a
una ausencia
[Música]
y la dejaron su hijo mayor de 24 años
que quedó paralizado tras ser alcanzado
por el disparo de un soldado israelí
[Música]
ras me su padre ya no va a las
construcciones donde solía trabajar
todas las mañanas se encuentra con
ashraf su vecino quien lo lleva al
hospital para estar cerca de su hijo
la bala le atravesó la columna vertebral
y los médicos creen que nunca podrá
volver a mover sus extremidades
así
sí no
al sumar a zurda
[Música]
fue en este camino frente a la casa de
los papás dejar uma guarany donde se
produjo el altercado con el destacamento
de israelí ese día los soldados estaban
registrando la casa de ashraf amour el
vecino
querían confiscar un generador y el tono
subió
un vecino grabó la escena
[Música]
en el vídeo
ashraf barhom y su padre intentan
recuperar el generador las imágenes no
muestran quien disparó el ejército
afirmó que los palestinos atacaron a los
soldados versión que negó ashraf a move
quien fue entrevistado por la policía
militar cuando viajaron justo cuando le
dispararon estaba así en esta posición
casi se había caído y trataba de
levantarse o no se estaba en esa
posición y le dispararon así hacia abajo
le dispararon así apuntándole
directamente a él había un soldado que
fue al auto para hablar por teléfono iba
a hablar y volvía iba a hablar y volvían
le dijo algo al oído al que disparó
parece que le dio la orden de disparar
no lo sé pero nadie intentaba tocar su
arma y nadie estaba cerca de él o
escondido como ellos dicen te dicen que
alguien estaba escondido y trataba de
amenazarlo eso es mentira nadie intentó
nada nada
el raquis su pueblo está ubicado en la
zona c la parte de cisjordania que los
acuerdos de oslo pusieron bajo total
control israelí las casas destruidas
forman parte del paisaje parte del
pueblo se encuentra en un terreno
declarado zona militar por israel pero
está prohibido construir e instalar
electricidad dos meses antes del
accidente los soldados israelíes
demolieron la casa que el padre de
haroon había construido para ello si
oyen el ruido desde allá y oyen el
generador funcionando se lo llevan lo
confiscan nunca lo dejan
no está prohibido tener un generador
pero sí construir aquí aquí toda
construcción está prohibida si nos ven
trabajar con ese generador hasta ahí
llega todo se los llevan junto con el
resto del equipo entran como monstruos
entran en la casa buscan y se llevan
todo lo que encuentran no solo el
generador
porque llevamos el generador la mayoría
de las veces porque cuando por la noche
no tenemos la electricidad de los
paneles solares utilizamos el generador
para iluminar para la nevera para lavar
la ropa que vienen no encuentran cerca
de la casa y se lo llevan aquí está cómo
se llama abigail que está allá y hay
otros bloques de colonias hacia el
bosque donde viven grupos de colonos en
una especie de refugios viven como
nosotros dicen que está prohibido para
nosotros construir pero para ellos no
está prohibido pero si nosotros
construimos una habitación minúscula
vienen con su excavadora y empiezan a
demoler miren esa colina todos ellos
ponen muchas más barracas que nosotros
en las colinas se vigila
[Música]
los colonos inspeccionan todas las
construcciones palestinas y están muy
organizados
es una escuela nueva que se construyó a
principios del año escolar en dos meses
lo consiguieron en la zona c en la zona
bienestar ilegalmente
y ya nos hemos quejado ante las
autoridades por esta regularidad
y tan y naomi forman parte de re gavin
una organización pro colonos que ha
hecho de la zona c su campo de batalla
puede que estemos en cisjordania pero
para ellos
la zona c es israelí y punto
sí claro
el año recorren kilómetros para
identificar los edificios palestinos que
consideran ilegales
eitán y naomi y recorren el edificio que
les causa problemas la escuela se
sienten ofendidos porque el ejército aún
no lo ha demolido por completo eso fue
demolido por el ejército israelí
bueno en la escuela mira lo que me
molieron ese pequeño montón de escombros
de allá
así que vienen toman una foto de ese
pequeño montón de escombros muy cerca de
movimos estamos haciendo cumplir la ley
pero la escuela que está justo detrás no
aparece en el encuadre así que tenemos
que ver a los tribunales cada vez para
decir dicen que la demolieron pero la
escuela sigue en pie muy pronto habrá
estudiantes allí empezaron a traerlos en
bus desde muchos lugares la escuela es
el ancla de todo un nuevo barrio es el
estado de israel debería haber detenido
su construcción antes de llegar a este
punto
eso es lo que queremos que hagan siempre
rega beam está parcialmente financiado
con fondos públicos los miembros
registran cada vídeo foto mapa para
emprender acciones legales el grupo es
influyente y ayuda a los colonos a
enfrentarse al estado con hechos
consumados
volvemos al raquis el pueblo de la
familia dejaron donde la electricidad
está prohibida este está rodeado de
colonias había ahí es la más cercana es
un puesto avanzado y legal según la ley
israelí pero conectado a la red
eléctrica aunque no lo suficiente a los
ojos de los colonos
no es fácil tener electricidad aquí
porque no tenemos por ahora
[Música]
bueno aún no está escrito al cien en los
mapas de maps eso es lo necesitamos pero
no quieren darnos más electricidad por
el momento no tenemos suficiente cuánto
queremos crecer no queremos quedarnos en
45 familias queremos crecer
mahón la colonia cercana es uno de los
asentamientos que se desarrollaron al
sur de hebrón rica fue de las primeras
en establecerse allí dice que es
consciente de la desigualdad que reina
en estas cuevas
uno de los temas de guerra con los
palestinos es el agua por ejemplo porque
como a ellos se les reconoce aún menos
que a nosotros no tienen agua corriente
dóger y si todo el tiempo tratan de
robarse el agua de los gipsy kings
los asentamientos que están alrededor
así que todo el tiempo tenemos problemas
nos quedamos sin agua
una descubra causa uy no me llevo bien
con ellos pero entiendo por qué han
llegado a este punto todo me metés
porque nadie hace culpa de ellos
pero el día comienza en casa de ella y
uno de los vecinos de rica
tres de sus seis hijos tienen que tomar
el bus para ir a la escuela
ya y dice que siente como si viviera en
la biblia desde que se instaló en esta
tierra que se ha convertido en una línea
de frente
el hecho es que hay una guerra
silenciosa las armas para esta guerra
son las casas
el bus blindado es el bus normal para
ellos pero si miran a su alrededor
entenderán por qué ven la vista todo lo
que ven alrededor no es judío en efecto
es cisjordania para allá y desde que
israel controla esta zona es el estado
de israel y sus vecinos los que tienen
que vivir con ello realmente quiero que
mis vecinos tengan una buena vida
quiero que tengan electricidad y casas
bonitas
pero primero tienen que entender que
este lugar es israelí
culpa al estado de dilatar las cosas de
mantener la ambigüedad en lugar de
simplemente anexar toda cisjordania la
llama por su nombre bíblico
judea-samaria israel no ha decidido al
cien por ciento tomar judea-samaria y
como israel no quiere decidir dice vale
aquí quien manda es el ejército conozco
al ejército el ejército sabe combatir el
ejército no sabe gestionar a los
ciudadanos ciudad
así que el gran problema es que el
ejército nos dice esto está bien esto no
está bien esto está bien esto no está
bien esto es muy nebuloso y si israel
decide que este lugar es israelí
este lugar será israelí pero el problema
es que israel no quiere decidir
los colonos presionan a las
instituciones para que adopten su visión
dominan la táctica perfectamente
frente a los palestinos desamparados
ellos son los que se benefician de esta
niebla en las colinas
pero no
gracias por acompañarnos a esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web más 24
punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]